Donald Trump is increasingly at odds
with America in terms of the protests
and Donald Trump is increasingly at odds
with his own officials will talk about
the America part a little bit later but
let's start here as you know Donald
Trump has been considering use of the
insurrection Act of 1807 to send US
military to States to quell protests and
in fact there were some troops deployed
yesterday but reportedly they were very
quickly called back by the Pentagon
still early reporting on that but there
seems to be a conflict brewing between
Donald Trump and the Pentagon there now
this barely warrants repeating for you
guys but I will repeat it anyway the
protests are mostly peaceful they are
also increasingly peaceful with every
passing day we see protesters policing
themselves more and more rooting out
people who want to cause trouble and
that's a very good thing to see well
Donald Trump is thinking about could we
maybe send tanks to the streets to
intimidate people and the Pentagon to
their credit seems to be not having it
Secretary of Defense Mark Esper has
increasingly distanced himself from
Trump's ideas on this we don't know
whether Esper will be fired within 48
hours that may well be but over the last
two days mark espera has been saying you
know my comments on Monday and Tuesday
they were mostly just general shows of
support for Donald Trump you know
telling governor's request military aid
if you need it but Esper reportedly
didn't really think Trump was going to
act on militarizing the streets against
governor's demands this is a huge
mistake by mark s / mark s /
underestimated the erratic and dangerous
nature of donald trump's out-of-control
authoritarianism what we are learning
and what every Trump official should
know by now is that it's very dangerous
to placate Donald Trump with the yes mr.
president the military yes sir mr.
president of course because now Trump is
actually asking hey what kind of tanks
could we maybe send to the streets of
America according to what a Pentagon
official told The Daily Beast and the
Pentagon listen the Pentagon is not the
good guy in the history of American
politics in GOP
politics there's no doubt about that but
the Pentagon seems to be making it clear
they're not looking to send in the
military and they're not looking to send
in tanks and once again I would not be
shocked if Secretary of Defense Mark
Aspar was fired within the next couple
of days I said this earlier and it bears
repeating this is not a rehearsal Donald
Trump is not distinguishing between
protesters and looters Donald Trump had
protesters smoked out to clear a path so
that he could take a picture with a
Bible in front of a church a few days
ago and I want to point out something
else a lot of either ignorant people or
bad faith actors you can never really
tell with some of these people they are
trying to conflate the state National
Guard with Trump sending in federal
troops and I really want to make clear
that there's a big difference here
National Guard's are run by States
governors for example a couple months
ago brought out their respective state
National Guard's for coronavirus related
help they've also brought out their
state national guards around the
protests that is completely different
than the president saying I don't agree
with how governors are handling this I'm
going to deploy US military to States
against the wishes of governors by
utilizing the insurrection Act of 1807
that is a completely insidious
authoritarian threat the state governor
saying we just need support from our
state National Guard
that's how it's supposed to work that
states rights and we shouldn't conflate
it we can still be against the
deployment of state national guards but
don't allow yourself to be tricked into
thinking if a state is deploying the
National Guard there's really no
difference with Trump sending in the
troops it is very very different now as
far as Donald Trump and his tanks Trump
has been desperate for tanks rolling on
American streets since he became
president of the United States remember
for a while he wanted a parade with
tanks he wanted it to happen for
propaganda reasons now Trump wants tanks
out there to repress protesters he just
wants tanks out there at his say-so
that's really what it comes to he wants
know if it's his own version of version
of Tiananmen Square or if Trump believes
that the strength that will be portrayed
by tanks rolling at his say-so will
reflect positively on him I don't know
exactly what Trump is thinking but this
is all authoritarian dystopia protests
repress them with the military tanks
roll them down American streets and by
by the way I mean this is like so minor
given what's going on
rolling tanks down American streets is
extremely damaging to the streets to the
roads in a physical sense I don't know
if Trump knows that but tanks are not
meant to be rolling down American
streets or better said streets are not
meant to handle the weight and
characteristics of tanks and you know
what who's going to repair that is Trump
going to pay for that Trump keeps
talking about doing infrastructure
spending and we're still not doing it
just like a minor coda to the broader
story that we're dealing with here we're
gonna have more on this a lot more in
fact on the David Pakman show Instagram
page david pakman show make sure you're
following us there coming up next
Trump's former Secretary of Defense Jim
mattis denounces Trump calls him a
threat to the Constitution and Trump
responds predictably let me put it that
way we'll talk about that next
privacy calm is one of our sponsors and
they're giving you $5.00 just for using
their free service at privacy calm slash
Pakman privacy's of service i've been
using for a while now I love it it saves
me a bunch of headaches it's completely
free and it's very quick to set up and
here's how it works when you pay for
something online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number privacy lets you generate
virtual card numbers the payments are
withdrawn from your checking account but
your real card number stays completely
private and you do it all with one click
you can autofill the card number in your
web browser on the phone you can create
12 virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits
freeze them delete them whenever you
want I especially love it for free
trials where you need to give a credit
card number because I can destroy the
virtual card number as soon as I give it
to the company
and I know I won't be charged in the
future if you're ordering food over the
phone why do I need to give a restaurant
my real card number I don't have to
companies don't have to know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free they
do have a paid version with different
tiers where you can create more virtual
credit card numbers per month cash back
rewards extra security features but go
ahead and sign up for the free service
it's a no-brainer companies can't charge
you unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft that costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy comm slash Pakman